on this episode we hit the streets of
New York again and India gets a fan
yes
Guerry be everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 133 of
the ask gary vee shell just took me sir
to her first baseball game here in new
york city kind of interrupted our
regularly scheduled vacation
obviously screws into the city from the
bronx to take a meeting quickly tonight
working tomorrow do another show
tomorrow
so we're squeezing a little bit of
askgaryvee in because all of you are
crying so much missing
Thank You India you're a little rusty to
the rock I was the point that you didn't
even move it I understand all right I
guess that's about it we're here outside
New York City downtown Broadway and
Prince had a good askgaryvee the book
call today that's getting rolling that's
exciting that's about it a little bit a
little bit down on the football season a
little bit worried about what I've been
seeing so far that's my other two cents
and India let's uh let's get into
the show job India let's do it
Carlo asked what should a goal be for
teachers this year
what should a goal be for teachers this
year I you know you know I'm cynical and
tough on the traditional education
system in the u.s. so I would say a goal
for teacher this year would be to find
one to three students that are clearly
not predispositioned to be successful in
the machine that is the education system
you know the one that's been built
you know 78 years ago and is being
crammed down our society's throats here
as the world has fundamentally shifted
cool so teachers playing within the
rules of the game that you play like all
of us I do it even though I'm a wild
entrepreneur you know we all do it we
all play in the confines and the rules
that we set for ourselves try to find
one two three of those kids
and instead of going through the cliche
things of like you know worrying about
you know them hitting the marks within
the game or medication or all the other
stuff that is being pounded maybe take a
step back and open up your eyes
especially if you're watching the show
and you're seeing this advice we're
aligned right if you're watching more
than two these episodes you've gotten
through the the stuff that I'm throwing
and you're catching and vice versa and
so we're aligned find the one two three
of the kids that look like me they look
like so many of the other people that
couldn't win in those dynamics but are
so so lucky and so many other ways to
win in the actual world that we live in
and try to give them a boost trying to
be that teacher I wish I could sit here
beside Senor Kennedy my Spanish teacher
in high school I wish I could sit here
and rattle off two or three teachers
that said that saw me for me and I could
give them DAPs right now and say yeah
you were right I was gonna be okay be
that teacher for those 1-2-3 students so
that they can in seven twelve fifteen
twenty to thirty nine years from now say
mrs. Boston she
was the one that knew in fourth grade
that I wasn't made for that but then I
would be special at my art for my
singing or my pitching for my selling do
that Joe asked do you think a company
staffed by 50 of your clones would be as
less or more successful in vaynermedia I
love this question 15 my clothes now
there's an aspect to this answer as well
you know I love being an egg a number
one and so I don't like listening to
anybody else so if you're my clone and
we can't listen to each other we may
conflict and may have major problems and
so the answer is if it's a direct clone
we would crash and burn and not be
anywhere close to successful as
vaynermedia because there'd be 50 people
trying to be number once if I could be
if I could have one ABCDE it all the way
through Z twice right short because
fifty two letters 2060s but you don't go
but if 50 of us could go from one point
one to 1.50 and go through that ladder
we would dismantle the earth and
dominate and be the greatest 54 forget
about 300 those warriors that wanted to
be 50 and we would dominate the universe
my intuition is straight clones we'd
lose clones with a tweak just an inch of
a tweak that allowed us to have that 50
person rank and people listening to each
other we would dominate earth earth
birthmother you did
have you gotten that simple no way we
are so Jimmy asked six years ago you
made a video called hey mister DJ about
curating content is this still a great
opportunity in 2015
Wow the truth is I'm actually now that
you bring it up I remember it t Rock I'm
just gonna guess I've no idea what I
look for like much younger much fatter
you know yeah I mean I think that
curating content is an enormous ly
important skill in a world of all the
content and she's creating content right
now you know I I think that in a world
of all the creation of content that's
going on I think we need curators to
help us some of it so I love nuzzles so
much right just got in the cab hit
nuzzle 12 headlines that I want to know
about Tech mean Jason her shirt by the
way hope you feel better brother his
email list media rep like yes curation
is massively massively important and
something that i think that we need in
our society
so man how are you
getting fans love it so I was wondering
what do you feel a high schooler who's
really into tech who knows how to code
has made an app should do in order to
guarantee success as a tech entrepreneur
after college that's my question
thanks there's something about this
kid's video that kind of hit me in the
stomach what I wanted to say to you is
very simply that it's well away it's a
good point before I get into it it's a
good good moment to tell everybody to
keep pumping out questions I am very
much watching and sending India stuff I
really want more more videos Instagram
or Twitter hashtag it askgaryvee I
really there's something about this kid
that really stuck with me I'm gonna make
a weird prediction I fundamentally
believe this kid is gonna be massively
successful and will email me this video
in 12 years saying hey cool and so you
know what I really want to tell you is
to hang around to hang around people
that you uh that you want to be like was
that another person second guy oh hey ty
it's up ty
Indian you can have more fans than me
I'd be very pissed
all right whatever tie hang around as
many people that you want to be like as
possible I have a funny feeling you have
all the pieces now it's about the
connections connections are grossly
underestimated I would intern every
summer between now and whenever you're
ready to do your own thing at people
that you want to be like for people that
you want to be like organizations that
you want to be like Network networking
was clearly the thing that I watched the
video and I was like Network kid just
get out there meet up com meet people go
on Twitter search just say hey to people
join as many networks get yourself out
there into the real world to give daps
say hive india because you went to
college with her you know that kind of
thing just get out there and say hello
to people meet as many people and be
around like-minded people be around
like-minded people be around winners
hustlers ambitious entrepreneurs spend
summers in San Francisco but there's
text scenes popping up everywhere but
it's about these five to six internships
that you can sneak in between now in the
beginning that I think will have
disproportionate value for you and don't
take an internship at Facebook or Apple
where you won't ever touch the genesis
the seed go to smaller places that are
people like you want to be like so that
you can taste it so you can be close to
it korban ask you talked a lot about
self-awareness do you think this can
prevent people from pushing past their
comfort zone I'm not sure what Corbin
means do I think self-awareness -
somewhere in like a pen on your screen
yes
you know
I think this is a very valid point that
a lot of people in my inner circle of
like intellectual friends who are
watching what I'm up to and know that
self-awareness is a theme of mine right
now argue with me that is a counterpoint
to my point which I have which I have
tremendous respect for but absolutely
I'm not scared of and disagree and
honestly believe that that's the norm
which is why the norm sits directly in
the middle and doesn't have that upside
so yes do I think if your hyper sense of
a hyper self-aware and know that you're
introverted or you just say to certain
things that you never explore the things
can there be some limitations I do but
to the point of choose self-awareness if
you actually know what you're best at
and what you're good at and you spend
time there you'll have the most upside
so yeah you could say well you're not
gonna be as well-rounded as a person I
would argue that by far the happiest and
by far the most successful people are
not the most well-rounded and have gone
extremely deep not extraordinarily wide
and that doesn't mean look I think I
play all over the place but I like will
it in one spot and so it's about
drilling that one spot and so it's a
great question so rememba you know d-roc
keep you busy a little because we don't
have any shows right now throw me up a
little bit about tremendous alert
tremendous alert it's a tremendous
question but one by the way the rock
show this thing it's really cool
I just just I just like it I just think
people should see that cart all right
get back your viewer it's a tremendous
question one that a lot of people need
to think about but I but my answer is
you know I don't want to hedge here my
answer is no I'm not concerned about
that really not as a matter of fact as
I've gotten older I've become more
educated more rounded into more things
because my success has given me
permission to do that and I think if you
go deep in the beginning that success
will come and then you can worry about
some of that secondary things in my
opinion which is rounding out thesis I
mean for truly something weird you know
when you're good at tonality missed out
on being the greatest singer of all time
so that's what I think that's a scoop
statement of the day I remembered I'm
impressed with myself right there I kind
of dreamt a couple times that I said
question today and you guys all yelled
at me statement of the day give me a
recap neither two sentence recap of the
show you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering